Fälle
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
es wird mal wieder Zeit fürs Mittag oder
Abend essen heute gibt's was ganz
schnelles einfaches nämlich ofenhähnchen
das Leben die Mädels und der Murat auch
mit Kartoffeln das ganze wird heute ein
bisschen ich würde jetzt nicht sagen
exotisch aber mal anders abgeschmeckt
nämlich mit Kokosmilch und Curry falls
ihr das nicht möchtet gibt's schon
zahlreiche Rezepte auf meinem Kanal wie
zum Beispiel das heißt begehrte und sehr
beliebte zitronenhuhn oder ein Hähnchen
mit einer Paprika Renate aber das hier
sind wirklich Zutaten ihr braucht
eigentlich nur vier Zutaten für die
Marinade und Salz und Pfeffer das war es
auch schon für die Soße nehme ich zwei
Esslöffel Sojasauce einen Esslöffel rote
Curry Paste einen Esslöffel
Agavendicksaft oder Ahornsirup 400g
Kokosmilch etwas Salz und Pfeffer und
das reicht dann für vier Hähnchenkeulen
dann kann ich jetzt hier die Zutaten
verrühren ihr dürft natürlich nach
Geschmack auch gerne noch Knoblauch
dazugeben
Sojasauce in die Kokosmilch einrühren
dann auch Agavendicksaft oder Ahornsirup
dazu
und die Curry Paste und diese Zutaten
haben natürlich alle schon einen ganz
ganz tollen eigenen Geschmack deswegen
braucht man da jetzt nicht noch ewig
viele Gewürze dazu Curry passt es toll
Sojasauce ist schon würzig deswegen hat
sich auch mit dem Salz etwas sparsam
sein und lieber mal abschmecken
[Musik]
und dann nur bei Bedarf
doch schon halber Teelöffel passt
und das ist jetzt eine ganz tolle
Marinade die ihr über euer Hähnchen
Gießen könnt am besten nehmt ihr jetzt
schon eure Ofenform legt die
Hähnchenkeule rein ihr könnt damit auch
kleine Chicken Wings marinieren zum
Beispiel
und das ganze auch gerne schon
vorbereiten
und können es dann auch wirklich 24
Stunden erstmal im Kühlschrank ziehen
lassen
jetzt hier schön drüber gießen
[Musik]
decke ich kurz ab und stellt in den
Kühlschrank und kann mich schon mal ums
Gemüse kümmern
jetzt geht's hier weiter mit meinem
Hähnchen das Hähnchen durfte jetzt gut
durchziehen und ich serviert dazu jetzt
ein paar Karotten rote Zwiebeln und hier
noch Kartoffeln wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr gerne noch Knoblauch dazugeben müsst
ihr aber nicht
Zwiebeln werde ich einfach nur vierteln
deswegen lasse ich da auch die Schale
dran
einfach vorne und hinten was
wegschneiden
dann links halbieren
und ich halbiere es jetzt auch noch mal
hier
und die Kartoffeln habe ich jetzt auch
gewaschen und je nach Größe werden sie
jetzt halbiert oder geviertelt
also ich ganz persönlich hätte
Süßkartoffeln genommen aber Murat mag
nicht so gerne es ist Kartoffel deswegen
nehme ich jetzt normale aber ich finde
so gerade zum Kokosgeschmack passen
Süßkartoffeln perfekt
und dann das Hähnchen auf die eine Seite
und dann kommt das jetzt hier alles
schön mit rein
und jetzt gucke ich dass ich das Gemüse
auch schon mal mit der Soße vermenge
gerne noch ein bisschen nach würzen mit
Salz und Pfeffer
und das Fleisch wird dann oben drauf
gelegt
das war's schon ganz schnell und einfach
und jetzt kommt es einfach in den Ofen
das dauert jetzt so etwa nur
Dreiviertelstunde bis Stunde und dann
ist das Gericht fertig und das kann man
wirklich wunderbar vorbereiten denn das
Hähnchen kann ja in der Marinade über
Nacht im Kühlschrank gerne ziehen dann
das frische Gemüse dazu schneiden und ab
in den Ofen
[Musik]
wir sind hier gerade noch fleißig am
trainieren
freut euch jedenfalls sehr Freitag auf
eine ganz ganz tolle Show auf eine tolle
Choreographie ja richtig hart die
letzten Tage meine Füße sind kaputt aber
alles gut ich freue mich richtig auf
Freitag und wenn ihr wolltet ihr weiter
kommt
das Gericht ist jetzt fertig und kann
angerichtet werden
Samira davon probieren
hallo hallo
Hähnchen aus dem Ofen
einmal hier für dich
das ist mit Kokosmilch
du darfst gerne probieren
darfst aber auch sagen wenn es Dir nicht
schmeckt ich habe noch ein normales
Paprika Hund für euch okay
ich liebe das
kann nur sein dass du ein bisschen mehr
Salz brauchst
mich doch
ein bisschen Salz
aber sonst ist übel gut
also ein bisschen mehr Salz würde ich
dazu geben ansonsten passt perfekt
ich hatte jetzt am Ende also ich hätte
das jetzt eine Stunde zehn im Ofen
und habe am Ende noch mal Grillfunktion
angemacht damit die Haut oben drauf so
richtig schön crunchy wird ich glaube
den Mittel schmeckt dann bin ich froh
und ich habe ein richtig einfaches
leckeres Rezept hier für euch kreiert
probiert gerne mal aus und schreibt mir
eure euer Feedback ich muss sagen mich
stört es nur ein bisschen tatsächlich
dass die Kokosmilch so ein bisschen ja
weil sie halt doch einen hohen
Fettgehalt hat so ein bisschen ne
klumpig geworden ist aber man kann jetzt
auch noch mal hergehen und sagen man
kocht die Soße noch mal auf und bindet
sie ab oder ich bin da auch so ich tue
dann einfach so mein Brot da rein so ein
weißes leckeres Brot ja
also die Mädels sind leise das heißt sie
sind glücklich und zufrieden jetzt schon
essen okay
also macht's gut
hast du jemals so ein leckeres Huhn
gegessen
auch gell
mit
vielen Dank für die Blumen
vielen Dank wie lieb von dir
manchmal spielt das Leben mit dir gern
katzenmaus immer wird das geben einer
der Tricks dich aus vielen Dank für die
Blumen
vielen Dank wie lieb von